[Applause]
thank you thank you very much for
sticking around after it's sort of like
intimidating to follow Wes thank you for
sticking around for my talk so this does
not seem to be working now my name is
Rebecca I am
a data scientist I live in DC so I am
here in town just for the rest of the
afternoon and then I'm flying back to DC
where apparently it's snowing so but I
work as the head of data science at a
small start-up that does digital media
analytics in DC but I am also one of the
co-creators of the yellow brick library
and there was a talk yesterday about
yellow brick and at some of you may have
attended Benjamin Bank fort who is the
other co-creator of yellow brick
delivered that talk and so this talk is
not really a yellow brick talk but
yellow brick sort of makes an appearance
towards the end so you'll see and I
think it will sort of make sense when we
get there but this is really a talk
about the other thing that I do which is
text analytics and so some people may
have seen the Fox book so it's a little
hard to see with the light coming in but
this is a book that we published this
past summer it's one of the O'Reilly you
know animal books and it's called
applied text analysis with Python and so
this talk idea sort of is something that
I started thinking about when we were
working on that book and it seemed like
it might be kind of a timely thing here
and it's interesting because today was
like NLP day at the conference there are
a bunch of NLP talks this is going to be
an NLP talk but with a little bit of a
visual analytics twist
so this talk is listed as being like
novice level so I'm not sure how many of
you actually would consider yourselves
novices but I'm gonna just do a little
bit of you know vocabulary and review
and the first like three or four slides
just to make sure everybody is on the
same page so just kind of to make sure
we all agree about what is the you know
what are we doing when we are doing
machine learning and we have you know
some number of samples of data and those
samples are represented by you know num
many numbers probably and what we want
to do is train a model that can learn
things about those samples and make
predictions about new samples that it
hasn't seen yet but if we kind of take a
twist on that and think about how we
would interpret that spatially what
machine learning really is is you know
given some bounded you know decision you
know very high-dimensional probably
decisions based how do we define regions
of decisions how do we carve up that
space to serve up predictions for points
in that space and points that can be
projected into that space so you know in
terms of vocabulary you know the words
this is kind of this is the language
that I'm going to use I know there's
variation sort of across different
machine learning communities but the way
that I sort of talk about these kinds of
things is I'll talk about instead of
samples I'll say instances so those are
you know our points and those instances
are composed of features and so if we're
thinking about you know a data frame or
you know table the instances are
probably the rows and the futures are
the columns and that is what's going to
make up our dimensions so the feature
space is the N dimensional feature space
where those variables live and feature
extraction is the kind of that process
and here I'm calling it an art because I
think that you know this is sort of why
data science
they're still necessary because there's
this kind of you know immense amount of
effort in creating features that
actually will be a predictive you know
so it's it's that art of creating the
decision space to make the predictions
so you know really simple example is
let's say we want to make you know
predictions about how thick a car tire
will be after its you know a set of
timed trials and maybe you know our
columns here are the features that we
know about are how far the tires had to
travel during the the test and how long
the test was and maybe you know how much
of a certain kind of chemical
preservative is introduced into the into
the tires to keep them from wearing down
too quickly so in this case we have how
many dimensional feature space right
three three dimensional feature space
but we probably have this sort of
intuition that you know distance and
time by themselves might not be enough
right we may have this sort of intuition
that how fast the car was going and will
have some influence on how quickly the
the rubber kind of burns down on the
tires and so we're going to do feature
engineering I will generate another
variable that accounts for speed and now
we have a new feature space right so we
have this sort of fee mapping between
you know our original future space into
our new feature space so can this be
done with non numeric data
it can so who in this room works with
other than numeric data like text data
or video data audio data okay so you
know a lot of you know most data right
is sort of maybe not coming at us
starting out out of the box and numeric
and we're going to require some sort of
transformation so that we can do machine
learning because in order to do machine
learning we have to have numbers and so
the trick is you know when we're doing
that transformation distance is sort of
not always a straightforward thing right
so when we're when we're looking at the
distance between two tires that are
represented in terms of you know the
speed at which they were tested and how
far they traveled and how much chemical
preservative you know there's you know
there's a kind of a maybe intuitive
sense of how you would define the
distance between any two tires in that
training data but with documents let's
say or videos or pictures how do you
make that decision about how to decide
if two pictures are close to each other
in space or far apart or you know how do
you decide if two documents are similar
right because that's sort of how that's
what distance means when it comes to
documents so there are a lot of
different ways to measure distance or
sort of define similarity you know the
the default so users of scikit-learn
show of hands probably you know most
people here the default distance measure
in scikit-learn is what
so it's usually Euclidean right unless
it's changed recently
I think that's usually the default and
the the kind of common mantra rule of
thumb for text data is to use what kind
of distance see use cosine distance is
sort of the popular choice and sometimes
cosine distance is the right choice but
there are you know just the way that
there are a lot of different you know
estimators in scikit-learn and there are
so many estimators and Benjamin talked
about this in his talk yesterday there's
so many different estimators to choose
from that you know it's sort of it
doesn't make sense not to try them all
you should sort of try them all
especially if you have a new data set
that you're not familiar with and you
don't kind of have an intuition about
what kind of model will be most
performant and it's sort of similar with
distance you know if you are working
with a new data set that you're not very
familiar with a new text corpus let's
say that you don't know very much about
there's no reason not to sort of
experiment with you know several
different distance measures to see which
one is going to be sort of most
effective at helping you you know
generate predictions so scikit-learn has
a bunch of options and actually most of
the options in scikit-learn are actually
sy PI options and there are a whole lot
of them not all of them sort of make
sense in the context of scikit-learn
estimators and you know a lot of these
don't support sparse matrices so that's
something to consider but this is just
sort of kind of a illustration of how
many options there are you know so all
of these options that you're sort of not
maybe not considering if you're just
using the default of what's and what's
inside kit learn and for text in
particular which is what I work mostly
with that work our choice is going to be
really really important and the reason
that it's going to be really important
is because a couple of things one is the
text is
high-dimensional and you know
essentially what you end up with is you
know a dimension for every word in the
entire corpus so across every single
document and if you're doing future
engineering and doing things like
diagrams and trigrams those are more
dimensions right so this is extremely
high dimensional and it's also going to
be very sparsely distributed right so
for most of the documents in that corpus
once we've kind of created document
vectors most of the values and those
vectors are going to be 0 probably right
because words are not going to occur in
every single the same words are not
going to are unlikely to occur in every
every document you know in the words
that do occur in every document are
probably not very interesting or
informative so some of the features are
gonna be a lot more important to us you
know so the example here is you know if
we're let's say we're trying to cluster
sports articles in a corpus of you know
hobbies documents about hobbies and the
of dimension is not as important as the
basketball dimensions but they both get
a dimension so that's that's kind of
tricky and then some future variations
are gonna be more important so if we're
trying to differentiate you know between
a bunch of different kinds of books and
some of the books or math books and some
of the books are horticultural books the
frequency of the word tree is maybe not
going to be as meaningful as the
frequency of the word horticulture and
that's because tree is going to appear
probably with fairly great frequency in
both kinds of books about you know cuz
tree is means something different in
math books but it occurs in math books
also so what do we do how do you make
the sort of decision about which which
distance measure is going to work the
best
so here's one option that I propose to
you so what I would recommend is that
you consider using something like
stochastic neighbor embedding or maybe
you map or you know one of the
variations may be a manifold
visualization this is an example of
something from the yellow-brick library
so you can do kind of like a one-line
use a you know one-liner to generate
this which is nice because you can do
kind of like rapid prototyping and do
quick analysis and get that kind of
visual feedback but you know what's
happening here under the hood and yellow
brick is that by default we're doing it
you know a dimensionality reduction and
then we're kind of embedding those
original points into it into a space
using probability distributions from the
reduced space in the original space and
then doing a simple 2d scatterplot but
what you get from this is you start to
see patterns in the corpus you sort of
see the distribution of the documents
you can sort of maybe start to see you
know that maybe if certain documents are
kind of clustered together the yellow
documents here which are the sports
documents are you know kind of fairly
closely clustered there are other you
know there are other classes that are
pretty diffuse you know pretty spread
out and so we already know that that's
probably going to be a harder category
to classify you know unless we do some
special feature engineering or feature
extraction so this gives us a lot of
information and what's kind of neat is
that you can pass in different distance
measures you know I just showed you all
the ones from Sify you can pass in
different distance measures into your
TSP plot and see how it changes and so I
was going to show you it like you know a
couple of examples so the datasets I
want I wanted to try if you try this
with a few different data sets these are
all data sets that you can find easily
so the the second to the farm ads corpus
and the dresses attributes corpus are
both from the UC
machine learning repository and the
first one the hobbies corpus is one of
the the data sets that ships with yellow
brick so you can kind of easily easily
get that so they're the three data sets
are all really different they're all
text corpora but they have a lot of
variation in terms of you know max dock
length
MnDOT flanks you know how many documents
are in the corpus and so this gives us a
chance to kind of examine across several
very different corpora what the effect
of different distance measures is going
to be so we'll start with Euclidean
right so this is straight-line distance
and the way that we are going to make
this happen in yellow brick is you know
you import you know from yellow brick
you'll import the TC visualizer and it
has sort of that same API style of sight
as scikit-learn so it's sort of familiar
you instantiate it and you pass in you
know keyword argument you say I want you
kill Euclidian distance in fact this is
what it will give you by default even if
you don't pass and you know keyword
argument but here just to be explicit
you know we're saying okay now fit the
TC visualizer on my documents and we
know the labels in this case and so
color color the classes with the labels
that I'm passing you and then what we
get is you know I think extremely
different results for the three
different corpora so the the hobbies
corpus which again is a corpus of you
know documents about like sports and
politics and stuff like that so you know
you can see that the TC plot is you know
in in some you know in some of the
classes there's some clustering but you
know it's not particularly it's not
particularly helpful like you don't have
a clear sense that this is going to be
something that's going to be easy to do
classification on right you don't have
these sort of really satisfying
tight tight dense clusters it's fairly
you know fairly
distinct the two classes in the ads
corpus and for the addresses corpus you
know it's a little bit of a blunder
right so you can you can maybe see some
structure there but it's not obvious
that euclidean distance has sort of done
us any favors so why don't we try you
know a few other distance measures so I
if we do if we pass in metric equals
city block right so that's going to go
and get a city block algorithm from Sify
under the hood on your behalf and and
it's going to give you a representation
of distance between documents as this
the sum of the absolute differences
between the two points which are both
instances of documents in the corpus so
this one I think has a very different
kind of you know effect this is you know
these are not terribly different
distance measures but you can definitely
see I think this one is the hobbies
corpus is you know much I would feel
much more confident about trying to do
classification on the habeas corpus
after seeing this version of the plot
compared to the one that we saw before
with Euclidean distance and the ads
corpus again is you know they're fairly
- you know - fairly distinct clusters
and the dresses corpus again is like a
little bit of a mess that there's a
symbol cluster that the green points
that you know that's maybe a little bit
you know distinct we can do chess board
distance by passing in the keyword
argument chebyshev this is you know a
special case of Minkowski distance the L
infinity norm this one I think actually
does better with the dresses corpus
which i think is sort of interesting but
maybe worse with the ads corpus that
here's a you know another generalization
in Kowski distance which is another
popular choice for for people who use
scikit-learn i think a lot of examples
you'll see people kind of manually
selecting to use Minkowski distance
for their machine learning problems this
gives us you know a I think a very
successful
clustering result for the hobbyist
corpus and probably you know slightly
again kind of a mess with the ads and
and dresses corpus Mahalanobis distance
here so this is going to be you know a
way to rescale the original coordinates
with the with respect to the
distribution of all of the documents and
here we have to in addition to passing
in the keyword argument for the distance
measure we also have to pass in method
equals exact so this is a scikit-learn
thing I feel like this is you know
really interesting kind of result here
you sort of like kidney shape but very
distinct that you don't don't get that
sort of same distinction with the other
distance measures so hopefully you're
sort of you know starting to see that
it's pretty cheap to you know run you
know a single line or two and test out
different distance measures it doesn't
cost very much but you may end up with
kind of a very effective way of you know
before you actually ahead of machine
learning before you try to do
classification let's say you know a very
effective way to kind of get a sense of
whether or not your distribution is
going to suffer from you know diffuse
classes or maybe like even a situation
where there are two classes that are you
know on top of each other and that maybe
classification is not going to be
possible without significant effort
cosine distances you know the the
popular choice for text but you know I
think what's interesting is that it's
not always the best choice as you can
sort of see from the the stochastic
neighbor embedding here you know just a
couple more this is really just you know
it's maybe a little gratuitous at this
point but just to show you know it's
it's so easy to kind of explore a lot of
different distance
before you kind of head towards the the
classification stage where you may you
know unknowingly be hurting yourself be
impairing your model by selecting a
distance measure that's not not
appropriate for your data set what do
you think Jaccard distance will do so
jacquard is a set you know set distance
so it's very different from you know
metric or vector space so any intuition
semester eight and so is hamming
distance which is I added these two
because I you know people generally will
ask about you know different kinds of
set distance or edit distances because
these kind of come up when you're
talking about text analytics but it's
another just good exhibit you know
example of how you know there's not sort
of a one-size-fits-all distance measure
you have to really make very specific
decisions on a per corpus basis because
you could end up with a distance measure
that's not good at all for you so in the
last kind of couple minutes here I want
to kind of give you a sense of how I
think that you know that kind of feature
exploration would fit into sort of a
more complete analytics pipeline and so
I'm sort of thinking of this in terms of
the what they say should you know
Schneiderman's mantra as this ben
shneiderman is a professor emeritus
professor who had did a you know a lot
of research into visual analytics and
the Schneiderman mantra is overview
first zoom and filter and then
details-on-demand so you know the
yellow-brick kind of workflow is really
perfect for this because it offers tools
for feature analysis for model you know
algorithm selection and for a hyper
parameter tuning that let you kind of
have that high-level overview of a
dataset or the performance of a model
and then zoom in to kind of a particular
class to see how a particular class is
performing or how a particular feature
is related to another feature if they're
Kovarian or something like that
[Music]
so here's you know maybe an example of
what you might do so let's say you know
we have a new data set we go through
kind of a bunch of TCE plots we get to a
point where we feel fairly confident
about our distance measure and we've got
this sort of you know we're asking
questions like what is the overall shape
of my data are there discernible
patterns do we think we can classify
this and once we feel like the answer is
yes
maybe then we do this is a lexical
dispersion plot behind me here and the
question you're asking now right so now
we're going to zoom in on a few words
and so that's what we've got here we're
going to look at the occurrence of a few
specific words across all of the
documents in the corpus and so we'll be
able to see their frequency and you know
if they are associated with certain
kinds of documents the gray dotted lines
there are document boundaries so you can
also use this to see are these words
that are occurring in documents that are
particularly short or particularly long
because those are also things that can
impact modeling so here's another
example that doesn't use TCE if we have
another visualizer in yellow-brick that
does inter-cluster distance mapping and
so you know another example of this sort
of like you know overview first zoom and
filter details-on-demand as maybe to
start with and inter-cluster distance
map where we're asking questions like
basically did I pick the best K value
right did I pick the right number of
clusters for my documents you know
because we all know that we've picked a
good k if our clusters are very separate
from each other and very dense and you
can kind of very quickly and intuitively
see that with the inter cluster distance
map and then once we sort of feel
confident about the K right so we've
tried a bunch of different K oh we've
done a bunch of these plots now we're
confident about our K now maybe we'll
dig into each of the clusters the
resultant clusters and do something like
a token frequency distribution and try
to see if we can figure out what the
most informative features are for that
cluster you know how would how would I
predict the
document was going to be assigned to
that cluster next time based on the most
you know the kind of most informative
words or potentially you know our a my
in a situation where I have a lot of
stop words that need to get filtered out
in which case you know you can kind of
do the cycle again filter out stop words
do another token frequency distribution
and then start to see what those most
informative features are of your
documents so you know I'm going to wrap
up here with a plug for yellow brick not
you know not just kind of to use it and
kind of dive in in fact I hope all of
you if you haven't already if you would
visit the repository and give us a star
and that would be that would be
wonderful and actually we just became a
numb focus affiliated project and so if
you go out to the num focus sticker
table there are yellow brick stickers
there that have the URL of our
documentation but I would you know
strongly encourage you if you are
interested you know if you feel sort of
inspired by West's talk about kind of
building you know building something
open-source together one of our sort of
aspirations as a library is to be the
you know the best place in github you
know in the open-source community to
give your first contribution you know
we're very very welcoming we both teach
you know most of the people on the
yellow brick team are people who have
taught machine learning or taught Python
and so it's a very hospitable kind you
know community that's very welcoming of
people of all different colors and ages
you know different genders and so it's a
you know I would strongly encourage if
you're if you're interested in becoming
an open-source contributor to check it
out if you're somebody who does a lot of
machine learning it has kind of some
interesting ideas for visualizers that
don't exist that you think should exist
you should also reach out and propose
them as future requests and if you're
using yellow brick and you notice a bug
please let us know but that's all I have
for now and I think there's a little bit
of time for questions
yeah we take one or two questions
don't be shy has anybody used yellow
brick in the audience not yet yeah
so I I would be delighted you know it's
okay if you don't have questions but you
know you know if you're if you're
interested in kind of checking it out
and reaching out to us has anybody here
ever contributed to open-source before
so not a whole lot of you so is anybody
sort of like did you kind of maybe touch
the bug from listening to West's talk I
mean he he makes it sound pretty cool
and I will you know be honest I think
that it's it can be a scary place it can
be a mean place so if you are kind of
hesitant or reluctant I think you will
be pleasantly surprised if you pay us a
visit and reach out to us questions
about yellow Brecker yeah I have have
you played with you map at all instead
of tease me for and are you would you
want to swap it in at some point that's
such a good question and what's funny is
that I gave a kind of a proto version of
this talk in up high did in New York
over the summer and somebody came up to
the came up to me after the talk and
said but basically a you know a similar
question and I said no but you know we
don't have that but that would be an
excellent contribution and he went home
and he wrote a new visualizer and now
it's part of yellow brick and you can
use it yeah so we do so you actually you
should check it out though because
there's definitely if you know it's sort
of a at first you know v1 kind of thing
but you should definitely check it out
and see if you have ideas for how to
expand it that'd be great yeah great
question Thank You Rebecca
so we're